hello and welcome to the virtual edition
of our year-round screening series film
independent presents and this q a for
the new amazon release sound of metal
i'm john wilson senior programmer with
film independent uh before we started i
ha
i have to give some praise to our
supporters
so thank you to our incredible lead
sponsor the hollywood forum press
association
our screening partner vision media and
also our media partner
the los angeles times for those of you
watching live today uh please do take
advantage of the question box at the
bottom of the screen
you can submit a question for me to ask
darius towards the end of our q a today
uh and now i'd like to welcome our very
special guest today the writer and
director of sound of metal darius martyr
welcome how are you jen it's obvious
it's it's just great to see you see you
yeah so i should explain you and i
met each other many years ago at the
2008 los angeles film festival
which was my very first year with the
festival oh yeah
where you premiered the documentary loot
which you also ended up winning
a prize for um and also
uh a very special moment between you and
somebody happened that was captured on
film and i'm gonna
share it here go man
it's so crazy well you could think there
it
is boom
[Laughter]
that is really like that's you and
guillermo
a life-changing moment you know but let
me
let me give you a little a little
background little inside baseball on
this
so you know imagine this
you know i spent years and years and
years and years making this
crazy movie loot i think i shot 500
hours for this movie and
you know i get to this festival i'm
broke i have
i can't i'm lit i was literally homeless
there i had i couldn't get
a hotel room and uh i was it was it was
that story
and someone said are you coming to the
hellboy premiere
and and i was i was i was kind of like i
yeah maybe i mean they were like oh well
you should come to the hellboy premiere
and i was like okay so i go to the
hellboy premiere
um with my friend my my dear friend
misha collins and i remember i just like
threw on a sweatshirt that one that gray
one
and i go and um you know before
hellboy guillermo gets up and he starts
describing
this film and then he i find that he's
saying
you know he says the word loot and my
brain can't really process this because
there wasn't supposed to be an
announcement
at the hellboy premiere that wasn't that
wasn't advertised
so i i find myself now i had leveraged
everything in the world to be there and
i had
you know kids at home and i felt like
such a
like at that point i just couldn't
believe how crazy i was that i had done
this and ended up at this moment
and he's announcing that i won which
came with a 50 000
prize which completely saved my ass
and i find myself on stage and he looks
at me and he goes you fucking deserve it
man
he's like you deserve it and i look in
his eyes and i'm like
you saw the film and he went no
[Laughter]
it was so great and and then this is us
outside and man what a beautiful dude he
is and it was just like one of the
true like transcendent moments in my
life
did he just wrap his arms around you and
pick you up yeah he actually said
something can i say it
it's yeah it's kind of it's it's kind of
hilarious
he said he said
don't you have a fucking heart on
oh my god i was like well i mean maybe
you know it was just amazing and and he
like yeah he's just
such an awesome dude but i have heard
that he likes to give hugs and he will
give anybody a hug that likes to that
wants to have a hug
i you know i'm i'm a huggy guy i'm not
afraid of a hug
and uh nowadays we should be but you
know
i'm i'm uh that was perfect for me as
you can tell this is a masterpiece of a
picture and i will always cherish it
oh it's so great i love it i love that
that exists
well it's great to see you jen it's so
good to see you too
i'm so i feel so grateful
to have
to come back together with you uh after
so many years
okay so here's the thing though i know
i'm interrupting you so i was working on
sound of metal when
guillermo was hugging me okay that's
that just to set the stage a little
yes like how long this has been
happening let's
let's let's back up a second i usually
start these q and a's
with everybody's origin story for how
you became a filmmaker because we have
so many
aspiring filmmaker members for film
independent
so what is your origin story because you
didn't start out
weren't you a chef didn't you used to be
a chef
well yeah i mean i i have
had some i've worn some hats i will
preface everything by saying
i started making films in my late teens
i i hustled to get an xl1
camera in my early 20s i started
shooting docs
i then was shooting i had a child early
and i was like hustling and i was
shooting wedding videos
and that's how i learned to edit so
let's just say
i had been doing it and i had and i
always knew
i was going to do it i cut a a super
eight movie together and
spliced it and projected it on a barn
wall and
um i was probably wearing something very
similar to what you're wearing now jen
when i did that yeah and i i um
and and i projected this thing with some
music playing next to it and i just was
like
oh my god you know it was i mean i
always loved film but i had that moment
of just like
i have to do this forever and then you
know i came from nowhere land in terms
of connections i'm not i never really
believed much in school
in general um so i
i come from a really you know
maybe hyper intellectual family
certainly on my father's side of artists
and um and geniuses
and scientists and stuff and i i kind of
i just
i needed to not be in school i wasn't
really school material
but i was also a very
kind of not reckless like i was always
looking for the edge in life
you know and when i was young before i
had a child
i i was pushing boundaries not in terms
of
drug use but in terms of just wanting to
find it and sometimes it was pretty dark
sometimes it was like i found myself in
the middle of deserts kind of like
you know hungry and cold kind of a guy i
was really it was really
it was really the like exploration of
the human soul and it was
and there were there were some tough
times back then and and
i when i was at a very very low point
um my middle school
teacher called me who was the only
teacher i ever connected with she's
an absolute genius teacher and she had
recognized something in me in the way of
writing and she asked me if i wanted to
come teach with her
and i came and um
it was like a light it was it was like
an angel
called me out of nowhere when i most
needed it and
so at a very young age at the age of 18
i went
and taught seventh and eighth grade and
um and i did it for four years
and the reason i bring it up is because
when i was teaching these kids
first of all i bring it up because it
shows up in sound of metal
secondly i bring it up because when i
was teaching these children
who were so amazing when i was teaching
them writing
and putting on plays and running
choruses
and doing all these things with these
kids that was
it was working with them that really
opened up myself
allowed myself to write and i think it
was essential
in my own journey so that was kind of my
school
was teaching children and then when i
was done with that i kind of hit this
like
how does how does one like myself go
from this place to making movies and now
i have
one kid and eventually another on the
way so if i jump forward
i had again hustling i'm just hustling
and
now i live in new york and
you know like i'm always interested in
this i see these young people making
movies and i'm like how the hell are you
doing that because
i i was i was like i knew i want to make
these things but how the hell do you do
it
and i say it i know i'm speaking to
people that are hustling like i've
always been hustling and i
i feel like people never talk about this
you know they never talk about the
hustle
and how you go from a dream to a reality
which i've always found to be so
perplexing
and um and for me it has taken
stark declarations of intention that's
the only way that i have done
anything i have never been given
anything so it's always been these like
unbelievably s like when i say stark i
mean really
betting the universe like going okay i'm
gonna put as much at stake as humanly
possible
and see what can happen and that's what
i've done over and over again in my
career and that
and and that has showed itself in the
form i i like to think of it as the
power of
no because i have said no
repeatedly in my life when it comes to
real when you really ask yourself what
do i most want
what do i most want in the world not
necessarily what do i most need but what
do i most want
sometimes you have to say no to those
things that are giving you what you need
and those are scary moments always and i
and my life has been marked with the
chapters of no
so that i i was hustling
you know i had uninsured children in
brooklyn trying to like
do this thing i was shooting wedding
videos and and you know
wanting to and i was writing but
really always pushing past those demons
and and trying to
get shit on the page and i was a food
stylist i was working for martha stewart
and
i hit this moment in my career as a as a
personal chef and a food stylist where
i kind of like realized shit
i could start making money doing this
like that's bad
you know i mean real money you know i
was starting to kind of
make i could make a couple hundred
thousand a year doing this work
as a food stylist oh yeah you could make
money doing that work
what what is a food stylist is that
someone that styles food for photos and
videos and commercials
yeah it's phenomenal work actually
people who work in that industry are
super
i met so many nice people it's a little
different than fashion i also worked in
fat in the fashion world too just
hustling i if fashion world is just oh
it's enough to make you want to
but but food styling's a little
different a little more down to earth it
was kind of wonderful work but it was
essentially
boring for me you know it wasn't it
wasn't a career i wanted it was just
something i
i could do and it was very enjoyable you
know you go to work
you go to a studio it's just you know
you're kind of like
you know cooking and doing your thing
and it's just great and you could make
money
and then i got scared i thought oh shit
i'm gonna get comfortable
doing this i gotta say no writes the
golden handcuffs right
golden yeah golden ish handcuffs and and
so i i actually did that i
i declared to the universe i'm never
doing this again
i called everybody i knew and i said
i'll never work in this industry again
goodbye forever and um
and there were funny conversations like
really i'm like yup bye
so uh a week later
i found myself literally a week later
and i i i forgive me if you've heard
this story but uh i found myself in a
sandbox
in prospect park and
this guy from utah who had just moved to
new york came and sat down next to me
and i'm we're watching our boys play and
i have been writing a script on
freehand on a pad of paper because i had
kind of declared to myself
i'm a filmmaker come heller high water
that's what i'm doing
and he sat down we started talking
talking he's a fascinating guy dan
campbell
really smart and interesting and
eventually he's like what do you do
and i said i'm a filmmaker you know with
an absolute assurity because i had
decided i was
and he said wow and then he started
describing this guy in utah to me
that turned into the film loot and i
said the treasure hunter
and i i said to him that day in the
sandbox said i'm gonna make that movie
and he said really and i said uh-huh
he was like what what if what have you
made that i can see and i said
nothing and he was like okay and and and
then he said i guess i'll produce it and
he was like what does that mean i said
that means you're going to pay for it
he was like all right and we had
martinis we flew like two days later to
utah and i shot that for five years so
that that was that was the first no
that turned into something really
life-changing for me um and then i kept
uh telling me if i need to shut up i i i
kept doing that
and basically long story short i found
my way into editing
at that point which i could do pretty
well ish um
i'm a very good editor but very like not
a technical person so i was i was never
i'm like
i'm a mess you know um so good editors
are much better than me
but i fell into editing again i could
make good money editing
um and i had to cut that off and say
no i can't do this i'm not an editor and
i'm not i cannot work for other people
i cannot make other people's movies i am
not cut out for it
so i had to say i can only make money
writing or directing
and that was my rule for myself and that
is when i started showing up in an
office every day and
writing when there was no goddamn money
for it and no hope of ever getting
anywhere
ever and it was just these those were
those are lonely days but that led to
to a place beyond the pines and that led
to
this movie which came from that degree
of intentionality
so uh sound of metal i think
i've read is something that derek c in
france was working on
yeah and um he asked you to collaborate
do you want to talk about um how this
sort of because he's a co-writer but you
ended up directing how did it end up
becoming your project
he isn't he's not a co-writer he's a
story by story
and there's a difference only if there's
a big difference in this case because he
literally didn't write a word of it
but on the other hand he did because
what he had been he
within two minutes of meeting derek 13
years ago and he is
such a dear friend and such a fabulous
filmmaker within two minutes of meeting
him we were talking
about this and and because he was
shooting
i was shooting loot at the time he was
shooting uh
this film called metal head and
metalhead
had derived from his own experience as a
metal drummer
derek's experienced losing his own
hearing and
he had been shooting this band juicifer
which is a two-person band a man and a
woman
who travel endlessly under a real band
and he wanted to introduce this
fictional element
to make it a kind of a hybrid and that's
where we really connected because i was
very interested in this narrative doc
overlap which loot kind of is a super
narrative dock although it's not a
hybrid
and and he was interested in this hybrid
so we kind of creatively connected
and and then meanwhile he was getting
blue valentine going
and we were talking a lot about that and
essentially blue valentine just took he
just made it impossible for him to pay
any attention to that idea
and then we started writing plays beyond
the pines and i remember even
saying to derek at the time i was like
the hell with anything else
that's the one you know because there
was something i
saw in that and felt so deeply
in this concept which i some of it i saw
very quickly and some of it took years
to develop
but but essentially he he gave his baby
up for adoption
knowing he would never make it and i i
i took it over at one point he said well
you finished the film i'm making i said
no
i'm gonna i need to make i need to start
it over i need to write this thing
it's not you're not making the film i
want to make even though i loved it
so there is the dna of that project in
sound of metal very much
um and in that sense he's a co-writer
but not literally a co-writer he didn't
write any of it i wrote it with my
brother
your brother uh abraham right yeah
um so i have so much admiration for this
film for so many reasons
but it uh
takes us into so many communities that
have felt i think misrepresented or
under underrepresented in
in other films which is the deaf
community and
the recovery community
in this story um
i actually found the asp i'm not in the
deaf community but i am in the recovery
community i actually found
that the recovery community aspects in
in this
to feel more real than than in
any other film that i had ever felt or
any other film or tv show it didn't
it felt real and not hollow do you want
to talk about
your things that you did to flesh
flesh out the aspects that have to do
with recovery
um and then also of course the
the what who helped you flesh out the
aspects that
that dealt with the deaf community
well first of all just the fact that you
say it felt real means a lot to me
because that's kind of my highest
aspiration um
and i think much of it was real
and you know i think it's you know so
much of this this dance of filmmaking
for me
is is about very similar to making docs
i i don't find there's energetically
much difference
um uh directing a dock then directing a
piece of fiction for me because
they feel very much about accessing
something sincere
and and real and and daring
and and kind of cultivating an
environment to find that
so in the in the realm of of
you know addiction and recovery um
first of all there was a lot of
groundwork i i have my own personal
experiences with it
and um and
but there was also a lot of groundwork
done just on the character building
level for rizz
he spent a lot of time in in groups in
various forms
not just um alcoholism or or
or addiction but also codependence
and you know interesting other aspects
of
of of that kind of under that umbrella
but then
a lot of what happened in the in the
deaf community so there is this overlap
of these two questions you asked now
number one you know shooting with
within deaf culture was very much about
um was was very much about deaf culture
representing itself
and i wanted to treat that as i would a
documentary i
i this is not a film so important to say
this because it's so easily missed
and even sometimes with the best of
intentions it's not a film
about deaf culture uh it would be
very hubristic for me to make that um
this it's not my world to represent
but it's a film that that kind of
invites
uh deaf culture to represent itself and
um and and in so far as i
i i obviously cast entirely from that
world
and it's part of why it took so long to
cast the movie because
as much as hollywood loves to talk a
good game about being inclusive they'd
not inclusive when you're trying to make
the damn movie and i can tell you that
as a fact
so i worked for many years to support
that vision
and what what that was was
looking you know casting locally and
finding people that had really
were really dealing not just deaf people
because deaf
the deaf culture is not a monolith so
it's
it's everything in many things so
finding people that had
had been struggling and working with
these issues very very specifically
and literally creating a a community
um joe's community joe's house
and the essential most essential aspect
of that
was finding joe and that was
really really tough and and coming
across
a person like paul racey who plays joe
was just such a
an extraordinary experience because um
he is a you know he's a two-time vietnam
veteran when i say two times two tours
he's
dealt very seriously with addiction and
alcoholism and
he's taught deaf aaa groups and
he's a coda his first language is asl i
don't think he spoke english until age
six or so
um so he's he's from deaf culture and he
he's joe and and there's and there's a
lot of
and that's that was essential in
creating the feeling that i think you
were speaking to
jen because because he
he you know
he understood what it meant to hold the
responsibility
of the group that he was going to be
holding
and that group was a group of real
people we did real groups
you know the aaa group that you see in
the movie we shot
we shot the whole thing you know
everyone had their own story
and i wish i had time to make the nine
hour movie
but um everyone has their own story and
their own
real what they brought and and and joe
as played by paul held that and he held
it in a way with so much
at stake and so much responsibility for
that that i think it
hopefully pervades the screen he's
phenomenal
it's absolutely one of my favorite
performances this year
um no special it's such a gift oh paul
well can i speak to one thing about paul
i i was driving to the land i had
i spent years finding the location for
this it was very hard to find the actual
house for a lot of reasons but i won't
go into it but i drove paul to this
house
and uh imagine this guy had been working
in hollywood for 40 years and no one had
ever noticed him
and here he has this role of a lifetime
and you know it was just like an
extraordinary experience so i drove him
to this house i have a video of this
actually and
he looks at this but he just starts
crying and he i i almost can't say it
because i'm such a softy but he he he um
he just he he he he looked at this house
and he just
he just knew the weight of it and part
of the knowing the weight
i've come to realize after working with
the deaf community
you know invisible disabilities
are so intense because we
you know the hearing world people a the
able-bodied people they don't understand
by looking at someone what people are
dealing with and
for people who aren't that or people
like
paul who have grown up taking care of
deaf people since day one
being a liaison between two worlds two
cultures
utterly unrecognized i mean we don't
know who codas are codas are children of
deaf adults
we don't understand that we look at paul
and say that's a hearing guy the
end well no not true at all he's from
deaf culture
people who grow up with that invisible
reality that is utterly ignored by
others
have a hyper empathy because they have
an awareness that
that we don't that that was brought to
my attention many many times in the
making of this
film as as an able-bodied person just
brought to my attention
it's like as empathetic as i think i am
and i am
uh and sensitive as i think i am and i
hope i am
it was just a learning curve constantly
because you know
for these all i saw through and through
throughout the deaf community
these were people that noticed things
and noticed each other
and moved to help before anybody else
would ever even know anything was
happening
that really really important scene
um towards towards the end of the film
between um paul and reuben when
paul tells reuben that he has to leave
the community um
uh brought up a memory that i had about
um
the controversy over cochlear implants
in the deaf community
and i was wondering if that was
something that you were aware of when
you were writing the film
um because i was watching the movie with
with somebody else and they and they
asked me
is he mad is he throwing him out because
he got the cochlear implants and
i was like well i don't know if that
could be a part of it do you want to
talk about
yeah sure the cochlear implants in the
deaf community
and this and the whether you think he's
he's being thrown out because of the
implants
yeah i mean first of all yeah i'm very
aware of that conversation
and as aware of it as i am i'm
loathed to to have an opinion about it i
don't really because i don't
really think it's mine to have an
opinion about it's it's this is an issue
to be discussed and grappled with within
deaf culture for sure
and and it's and so i'm i'm very aware
of it and i've done a lot of talking and
thinking about it
but um it it's always interesting how
people see that scene
because you know i first of all just to
say it i don't have an opinion about
cochlear implants it's not the point
it's it's not the point at all and um
it's interesting that some people fixate
on it uh
when they see the film and others don't
um but but like for me
you know cochlear implants are not good
or they're not bad this is a decision
people have to make individually
they represent a fascinating dynamic
because
deaf culture if you remove if if
everyone were to get implants from day
one it would be the end of deaf culture
and so it's just a fascinating dynamic
and once again it is not something that
i necessarily have an opinion about
what is reflected in the movie is the
opinion of of of many and there is
there are deaf communities with a
capital d
that don't believe in that technology
for that exact reason and it makes a lot
of sense i think we can all understand
how
we can all see that that eventuality um
the movie and that moment that you're
you're speaking to um
there's two things going on and
um number one yes reuben gets an
operation
um and but
what does ruben do to get that operation
you know it's it was a fascinating
balance
in the in the in the writing and the
creation of the story because
reuben at once has a foot in the
community and another foot out of the
community
and and i i it was a it was a meditation
on
you know this concept and sickness of
fixing things this idea that we're
constantly looking for
a fix there's a reason that you know
there's a reason it's called sound of
metal
the reason that music so loud in the
beginning
reuben is constantly trying to get back
to that sound and this idea of getting
back to something
can be extremely dangerous and can we
really ever get back
can we really ever go back and what does
that mean
when we are fixated on that and
i think it's something we're all
grappling with right now everyone's like
i can't wait to get back to normal you
know back back back you know we may not
we may not there may not be a return to
a life we used to have before kovit
you know um and what is it to to
to actually accept that and what kind of
a hell do we live in when we cannot
so so what in that scene there are a
couple things going on
he what did he do to get that operation
well you saw him sneaking in and out
you know he was he was undermining trust
and undermining trust in a group that
in for whom for which trust is
essential that that an undermining of
trust is
actually going to kill people um
do do we believe that had ruben gotten
that
operation and decided to get that
operation
that that joe would have just said
goodbye we have no use for you anymore
does that seem like who joe is is that
really the hard line he's running or
does this have more to do with reuben's
actual addictive tendencies in that
moment
um and so i i'm fascinated with the
dynamic that can and might occur in this
movie where as
hearing people we fixate i wanted that i
was essentially creating that an
experience
that hearing people or able-bodied
people can watch this movie
and find themselves fixating in the same
way that reuben is
yeah this is the this is in particular
one of the scenes that i think will
resonate really deeply with the recovery
community because i i saw it but i was
not watching it with someone who is
sober
and when i watched it or you know
they're not part of the
of the 12 steps community uh i was like
oh he's throwing him out because he's
lost his sobriety
um but i can see how that and and that
losing your sobriety
doesn't necessarily mean you've used
right it doesn't mean that
necessarily mean you've used alcohol or
drugs it's that you're engaging in
addictive behavior again and remember
and remember
does he ever use
right i mean no so so essentially he
came in as a person in need
having never used you know and we know
we know this about addicts
like we know that's a reality that's a
truth
i mean look at uh philip seymour hoffman
you know
that that these moments come where we
get into an addictive spiral and if we
don't get that help and we don't
aren't able to get that help it can be
deadly
so yeah i want to talk about how the
story structure of this sort of
subverts your expectation right away
because
normally what would happen is he would
start to become deaf
he would start using she would start
using they would spiral down the rabbit
hole of drugs again
and then in the end find sobriety again
but
instead what happens is she calls their
sponsor
exactly right or who i assumes their
sponsor yeah exactly
exactly um hector
and i was like you know what i feel like
so
many writers don't choose this direction
because they don't think that starting
with sobriety and staying with sobriety
is going to hold the tension but
obviously in this movie
there's still so much tension there's
still
despite the fact that he doesn't you
know do the familiar thing of going down
the rabbit hole of drugs you still
maintain an incredible tension in the
film
uh do you wanna did you did you see
yourself as sort of subverting that
story structure when you were writing it
yeah entirely and i was much more
excited
to do that than the other and as a
matter of fact i wasn't excited to do
the other at
all um i i think it's so much more
interesting
to try to hold that tension without
using i think it's so much more
interesting to
you know like a horror movie where we're
scared of the monster we don't
see that to hold
that monster and never ever see it
so overtly as the using but to see it in
other forms like we were talking about
in that other scene
that was a much more difficult film to
write it was a
much more difficult film to create and
make but
so much more interesting to me and um
it's remarkable that people sometimes
over and over again people talk about
uh you know this yeah the addict story
is being predictable but there isn't any
this is not that and uh i at least not
for me and i
the journey of creating it was far from
predictable but what it really meant
was holding a truth
in every moment that was really really
specific in order to hold that
um to maintain that tension even while
you weren't using
it was it was an extremely difficult
thing to do
both in the writing and then again in
the editing um but what it meant is you
know in the shooting is having that
intentionality in every moment and
and i i kind of saw it as like caring so
much
for the re the characters you see on the
screen or feeling their real human
selves that you so desperately didn't
want to see that undermined
you know you didn't you did you know so
you hold that tension
uh throughout and and then
i you know shockingly the thing that you
think that you're fixated on the fix
you know the play on even the word fix
becomes this
again a a representation of that
that monster that was in the very first
frame of the movie
you know um
the ending of this uh is really special
and
i i loved the choices
that you made for for the ending um you
know where
um reuben's character sort of ends up
was this something that was sort of
difficult to formulate
um yes
because it really was i was watching it
with someone who watches a lot of tv
yeah they were sort of at the end they
were like well what happens
is he gonna be okay and i'm like well
i said you're used to watching a format
of
of television filmmaking where all the
outcomes are given to you all the time
and that's what you come to expect
and in this film you're not not
necessarily given an outcome
um but i think you're given i think
you're given some clues
so how do you as a filmmaker decide how
many clues to give
as to where reuben's going next
well i'm very interested in pushing the
boundaries of that i mean
my favorite experiences in in film
watching films are when i think we have
this incredible capacity as humans to
create contexts and create entire worlds
that are not
on the screen and though and that and
that wonderful thing
only happens when when the viewers
are trusted and when they are not held
when their hands aren't held
and if if you can get to that it's a
very high bar for me anyway i
i i really really like to push for that
so um and i think it's all over this
movie where
like you had said the sponsor and you
know it's never you're never told it's a
sponsor you know you
your brain has to kind of sort through
this who are they calling like what
he was smoking what did that mean
because that's the first moment there
even addiction shows its face
you know so again it's it's that kind of
language that
i i spend a lot of time on and think
about ways that we can
create muscles in in the viewers
because i like this i like when i feel
my brain engaged in a movie where i go
oh i gotta watch a little closer and i
have to listen a little harder because
i'm not gonna morgan freeman isn't
telling me what the penguins are doing
you know um so uh the
the the end of the movie is very much
that but
on the other hand there is some very
very specific language at least from me
in my intentionality about the end of
this film and
some of that has to do with you know i i
don't know how much you want to get into
that but the
the first of all the ending was
something
that was this true north that i always
felt i had to earn
and earning that ending which is a very
visceral
ending actually it's an it's an ending
you you i you feel
i hope rather than just think about
um because it's something that is an
actual physical
reality you know it's it it it's that
cutting off that that literal
silence so earning that
was was very important to me and part of
that meant going through a grueling
visceral process
you had to go through that so you know
it cannot if you slather this movie with
score
you can you don't earn that ending you
you again score in films is
always do it that's a morgan freeman
with the penguins
score is telling you what to feel and
holding your hand
almost invariably and so this this is a
much more visceral process
and you you're working toward earning
that
ending which hopefully involves a kind
of a fundamental feeling of truth
which isn't about what he does next but
it is about the essence of what
happens in that moment and you know it's
a it's a direct
reflection of the first scene of the
first shot of the movie that last shot
and it's
you know i i i had a kind of a an
interesting diligent cinematic language
in this movie because
i i really did want it to feel pretty
naturalistic and not showy
i i don't love when you are kind of like
wow what a dp
you know where you're you know you've
got these crane shots and all this crap
i i wanted it to feel natural but it's
also very diligent in its perspective
there isn't a pov
for the most part in this movie it's
it's it's an ho it's an it's a poh
it's a point of hearing and part of that
was not was about actually signaling
that we're not doing this like when
reuben looks out the window in the
beginning
in the airstream you don't look out with
him you're actually in his
point of hearing in that moment and part
of that is kind of getting into that
echo chamber
that thing that noise you hear in the
beginning before you see the frame
the sound that precedes the image that's
that's
that's that internal world we just don't
know it yet
and you know so so and that's how the
movie goes
you don't you don't do that until that
last scene
um that last scene is a point of view
and it gives way to a point of view and
it's suggestive
perhaps that we begin to see
and and what is it that get that gives
us our ability to see
and to take in and why is it that the
the
why is it that this one thing when we
were hearing and this noise inside
creates almost something that feels ugly
and then in another moment can feel
beautiful and transcendent what is that
you know it it does you know that moment
that moment of pure silence at the end
of the movie felt like an incredible
relief
to me after all the sounds preceding it
and the imperfect nature of the sound of
his implant
i was like he looks relieved to take the
implants off and i felt relieved at the
silence too
and i was like it just works so
perfectly for the end of the movie
yeah and no and it's a beautiful way to
put it as just relief
but the relief isn't the absence of
sound the relief
is the is the intentionality behind it
and i think that's what's so important
about this
is that you know deaf people don't
necessarily have a quiet within them
you know that quiet when joe's saying
have you ever
sat and had a feeling of stillness that
isn't about quiet
you know we can have quiet without
stillness so
that relief is about stillness more than
it is about quiet
i'm going to ask some questions from our
members
uh this is from matt warren how much
of the sound design was written into the
script and how much did you discover
trying different things out in the edit
well there was a lot of sound design
written into the script it was always
always going to be that uh but but
best laid plans you know some things
have to shift uh
the so but much of it was
this isn't really a language you could
have possibly done after the fact
it's way too uh specific for that so
we i actually met my sound designer
way before we began shooting over a year
and we started working on this and then
i would
got my sound designer nikola becca and
daniel bouquet who shot the film
we all spent a lot of time together
starting to sort out how do we marry
sound and picture for this for this
reason how
how do you start to think and i maybe
it's my years as an editor but i
you know really really really thinking
this way how do you use the cut
to start kind of transferring this
this uh perspective it's actually a
really complicated language it was
very tricky to figure out that so you
had to be
precise in it and um and then there were
some revelations also
you know there were plenty of them in
the cutting and this phenomenal editor
um mikkel who is just so such a
you know a special guy and and and
really talented
and so you know finding that balance of
how far can you push the audience
what's too much when does it become an
idea versus a reality
when is it when is it you know that was
really important and really tricky but
also pushing
more than you might be comfortable
pushing you know that was also important
so um and then the sound mix
the sound mix itself was 23 weeks long
for this movie it was
six times longer than the shoot you know
it it
it was such a bit of heavy lifting and
that was also about
really dialing up that experience and
figuring out where what that balance is
between diegetic sound and omniscient
sound it was just a wonderful creative
but grueling process
so speaking of grueling uh my next
question is for you what was
the most difficult part of production
for this film
oh man most difficult part you know it
was interesting when you say difficult
because
i really enjoy all the aspects of
production like i
i really enjoy it i like i i like
location scouting
i like writing i like production itself
shooting is just
is just such a joy for me um
i mean just really joyful experience
and um and
i love doing this i love post i love the
editing and
al so but all of it's hard um
you know so i i just want i just i guess
i separate this idea of striving
and being and and and being difficult
because i wasn't unhappy doing any of
those things
but it was freaking grueling i mean
there were if i if you could flash back
i kind of have to like call myself and
laugh a little because if you could
flash back at me
like like just in a complete fit
while we were doing like this you know
so it would be hilarious if you could
actually flash back and people who
know me and and like hear me doing this
i you know
i'm pretty intense but i like that
i want that in life and and i had to
fight
super hard for this sound
um the okay
i think the early stages of picture
editing were the hardest i i think that
i i my i was so it was it's
so hard to watch assemblies
after you shoot because they suck and
and
it's it's something that i i because i'm
an
editor and a pretty good one and again
i have good editing instincts i i think
i need to qualify it just because
like michael's a good editor i'm not a
good editor but i have very good editing
instincts and um and because editing is
just writing
it's storytelling so um
well but i looked for an editor for a
very long time that was better than me
and not gonna take my shit that was like
what i was really after
and so i kept telling editors what i
wanted
and if they said yes i wouldn't hire
them i was looking for someone that
pushed back and when i met michael i
said
here's what i want we're gonna do this
together we're gonna sit in a room i'm
gonna take this and you're gonna take
that and we're gonna do this and he was
like no that's not the way we're gonna
do it
he was like i'm gonna do this myself um
you're not gonna be around for a while
okay
okay and he said because if we don't do
that
you'll never know what i'm bringing to
the table we won't know what's you and
what's me
this is exactly what i would have said
to someone who if i were cutting their
project
and man i was just like oh my heart just
went yes
you are the man for this you know so i
gave it to
mikkel and then i showed up in denmark
and had to look at this
freaking four hour rough cut and and you
know that was probably
i didn't sleep one wink that night
you know it was so hard it was just
genuinely so
maybe to just you know really sincerely
give you an answer
that was the bottom for me i was it was
so important michael understands rightly
that you have to be willing to go
through that in order to get to the
other side and he's
exactly right but boy it is brutal
well so we're out of time but i want to
talk about
i saw you tweeted something about um
how to watch this film on amazon and
it's actually with the subtitles on
correct do you want to talk about why
well it's okay to watch it without it
but the the the
open captions is something that
i fought really hard for for this movie
i don't know of another movie that's
released in theaters with open captions
i'm i'm really
there have been movies and i think it's
important to say the deaf community has
made them
it's just that maybe maybe a lot of
people haven't watched them
which is which but so i'm not the first
to do it but
um mainstream movies don't and and
you know so if you think about this
without pointing a finger or even
casting
like you know a movie like a quiet place
it's it's you know yay a real deaf
person
but you don't you didn't open caption
your movie what does that really mean
and it's remarkable that we didn't talk
about it like nobody talked about this
you
made a movie with a deaf person that
everybody celebrated the fact that it
was a deaf person
but you only subtitled the asl so what
does that mean
you made a movie for hearing people only
and
if a film happened to have closed
captioned in some theater and
at certain times then deaf people could
go but otherwise they couldn't
it's it's not okay um and and this is a
a a wake up that we need so i realized
at a certain point
very very quickly my my grandmother my
incredible
gay jewish cinephile grandmother went
deaf
after taking an antibiotic too young and
she descended into
alcoholism and took over but she she
petitioned for the rest of her life for
open captions
so i dedicated the film to her and
she was a big part of it actually um and
for me
and uh and my brother and
i realized jesus oh my god of course
of course this has to be open capture
that's a hard thing to do as a filmmaker
because you don't really necessarily
want words
but as i struggled with it and worked
with captions and worked with deaf
people
i found it just became remarkably
creative and i found it transformed the
movie
so i do encourage people when you stream
it to turn the captions on
and i would i'll give you this little
easter egg which is that the title of
the movie is a caption
and so there's a real direct correlation
sound of metal it's not the sound of
metal sound of metal sound of birds
sound of tires
sound of metal is is is a caption and
the movie should play
playing captioned is a real interesting
experience so i do it i do encourage you
that was not a short answer i can't do
it jen i just i know you can't it's okay
i love you for it
i really wish we had the whole rest of
this year to talk
because i love you and i miss you so
much um
man i feel the same when you when you
tweeted that i went to amazon to check
it out and i noticed that they actually
have
descriptive capability um enabled on
this too
which i've never seen before for so
that's
so that blind people can watch the movie
too so so phenomenal
amazing i think we're gonna i think
we're ushering into a new
a new time a new chapter of awareness
around the stuff which i'm psyched about
well thank you so much uh this made my
whole
day for you to come and talk to me about
this film
congrats on the movie um congrats on
um life and everything and being you
and um good luck for the coming awards
season
thank you we are going to hang
just yes we are going how some way it's
gonna happen
we're gonna in the future okay it won't
be like the past but it'll be like the
future
okay thanks so much
it's so great to see you again